top 10
chris sims quarterbacks
midway through
the season i hope we're going to do a
side by side of june and now because
i don't remember the list exactly yeah
from when we did it this summer right it
looks a lot different now it does well
and yeah uh do you want to go from the
bottom to the top at the top to the
bottom well since we've unveiled the
whole thing let's start at the top
patrick mahomes he was number one he's
still number one what a shock he's
patrick mahomes exactly yeah i mean that
that's a no-brainer it really isn't i
mean it just there's just no situation
anything i mean there's no weakness to
his game really you know we've talked
about it whatever it is movement
decision making appropriate throws
clutchness ability to make things happen
off schedule ability to make things
happen when there's nothing there to be
had
he's the most special quarterback we
have in the sport so that was a
no-brainer
and he's now the favorite to be the mvp
after russell wilson had a couple of bad
performances that made him no longer the
odds-on favorite
now i think wilson was two yes and oh
aaron rodgers was three right you've now
done the flippy flop and you've you're
back in aaron rodgers good grace yeah
yeah yeah i'm trying to kiss his butt a
little here down the stretch of the
season but you know listen realistically
hey how could the not the last four
weeks change my mind a little bit about
how those two match up i mean they're
both awesome we know that amazing
russell wilson's still phenomenal i
don't care about the turnovers or
anything like that you know but yes when
i'm comparing them to aaron rodgers and
i'm going whoa these guys are both
awesome how am i going to separate that
you know yes uh russell wilson's lost
three of the last four and you could
certainly argue that you know he was a
big part of why they lost some of those
games you know aaron rodgers this year
hey the tampa bay game we can we can pin
on him sure the way he started off some
of those turnovers but other than that
come on the game everything goes through
him as it does russell wilson and he
doesn't even have the same type of
talent around him as russell wilson and
he's been making it happen and they've
been a machine on offense so i think
roger should be second to my homes in
the mvp wrote voting right now just to
where it stands right now but hey this
was very close but the fact with the
turnovers of the last three weeks that
that did you know persuade me to put
rogers in front of uh russell wilson at
this moment
here's where it becomes extremely
interesting we have seen major jumps
from 12 and 18 respectively to four and
five now
my guy red your guy blue kyler murray
josh allen
uh that's a hell of a jump oh but you
know what i think especially for murray
it's deserved alan
it's it's it's been a little rocky since
starting 4-0 but but still they're hey
they're winning they're getting it done
so i i can get behind this as of right
now murray for allen 5. yeah i i this
was this was a like a close one to me
too where i thought a little bit there
for a while i was like man who do i want
to put here ultimately i go with kyla
murray you know kyla murray and josh
allen if you remember at the time we did
the list back in june and all that i i
said i said man these are two guys that
could be in the top five conversation
when next year's over there they're just
so talented and i give murray maybe the
advantage of course because
you know the way he manages the game at
times the running ability
the running ability that he has is so
special
it changes
the defense and how they want to play
josh allen's offense is better than
kyler murray's he has more of a creative
offense to throw the ball and do that
you know i don't think the arizona
offense would look as good throwing the
ball and everything else if they didn't
have the threat of whoa we have a really
special running quarterback too he
really helps all of that out and that to
me is where i gave him the advantage
over josh allen but you know again
you're gonna see here in these top four
or these top five quarterbacks these are
all guys that
you know
it's them the team is it's about them
the team is built around them the way
they play every week is about them and
the pressure they apply to the team and
that's where i go yeah from that
standpoint these guys in the top five
that's why i think they're they're there
and that that's why i got them there
i want you to take the top five and i
want you to rank them under this fact
okay the guy with the most help around
him to the guy with the least help
around him of your top five okay uh we
know number one's in my home yeah my
home is just one all right and we know
number five is rogers
we know that is it rogers or is it
wilson i i guess it's roger yeah because
i mean i'm just gonna go okay he's got
dk he's got tyler lockett you know he's
got some other in-between receivers and
greg olson that are good and when chris
carson's healthy you know rogers yes i
know devonte adams and aaron jones but
i'm gonna say he's he's five so mahomes
won
ooh i'm gonna go kyler too
no yeah move yeah i'm gonna go kyler ii
josh allen three
russell wilson for
aaron rodgers five i think that's are
you just basing that on offensive help
or total team health no i'm a quality of
team or just i was just going on
offensive help just like the weapons
they have available to them and that's
where yeah it's close kyla murray or
josh allen i don't know i you know this
is another thing where i'd like to do
this list like offensive weapons who's
the top 10 teams in football with
offensive weapons but i don't know would
you take hopkins christian kirk larry
fitzgerald um and andy isabella and like
kenyon drake and and edmonds over
josh allen's supporting cast of diggs
beasley brown you know singletary moss
what what would you that's that's a
close one to me what would you do there
i uh
i i deandre hopkins is the tiebreaker
right yeah yeah i think so i think he
makes up for
uh for all and and you know what they do
have a pretty good they got a hall of
famer and larry that's what i mean yeah
kirk is pretty good yeah yeah so
isabella if you know yeah right i'd go
with cardinals i agree with you on that
all right there's a question from
twitter at d mathis 14. should josh
allen be above caller murray it looked
apparent last week he's a way better
passer and still has legs he is a better
passer i i do agree with that it's very
close as i just mentioned i mean it was
i was splitting hairs here and i you
know i kind of think i answered the
question a little bit the reason i
picked uh kyla murray
is yes
just a little bit of that running
ability and what he does for his team is
that it's that special you know and josh
alvin listen he has some of that aspect
too
but it's not to the point of kyla murray
and he is a better passer and dangerous
there but yeah i think tyler murray you
know even the way he manages games and
does all that too i just give him a hair
of an advantage i think in those two
categories to where you know i make josh
allen five and murray four but as you
know i love both
the next guy after the top five is
deshawn watson the texans quarterback
jackson's obviously struggling this year
question from m gilroy nine poor watson
he's truly the third guy i would start
my franchise with after mahomes and
kyler get him out of houston not really
question as much as a command yeah get
him out of houston a little too late for
that because he signed his extension
he's going to be in houston for a while
and he's the guy they're trying to build
around but it is sad to see a guy whose
career
is being wasted on a team that that
doesn't have the help around him that
allows him to be the best quarterback he
can be chris yeah it is you know they
they hopefully they can fix this and and
get it right you know we've seen hey
we've seen arizona we've seen the miami
dolphins really flip their team over in
one year you know can they do that and
start putting the right support system
around desean watson he's special i mean
hey listen uh i i don't disagree with
what what mcgilroy nine is saying there
in a lot of ways you know you're you're
right he he'd be one of those guys where
i maybe would think about him third to
start an organization he's got it all he
really does there's no aspect of his
game that is not you know
awesome um i he is in a tough spot with
a team that again just like the other
guys in the top five it's all about him
except he just doesn't have enough
support anywhere to kind of help him out
but man when you really study how he's
played this year has it been perfect no
but it's been phenomenal i mean in a lot
of ways they they would have zero wins
if they don't have desean watson they'd
have been blown out of some games by a
lot more if they don't have desean
watson you know and the other thing too
where desean watson hey
he's he's a special thrower he's a
pocket quarterback
and
i'm just going to talk about number
seven i made lamar jackson right and i'm
just gonna go that one was i first split
hairs but i went you know what
okay desean watson's a really special
pocket quarterback
who has the ability to run and i think
you know that puts more pressure on you
than lamar jackson who is yeah has a
greater ability to run but i think is a
lesser pocket quarterback than deshawn
watson i don't think that's even
comparable at this point so that's where
i put you know watson six and lamar
seven
and it was just three years ago that
watson was taking the league by storm as
a rookie while patrick mahomes was
sitting on the bench i mean think of how
much the league changes i know in a
relatively grand scheme of things short
period of time three years ago it was
watson watson watson he went up to
seattle richard sherman went to him
after the game and said you've played
better against his defense than any
quarterback ever has
torn acl in practice non-contact
remember watson told us after the season
he thought it happened on a hit in that
seattle game that that's what got it to
the point where it was ready to go and
and he's been struggling ever since then
to get back to that point where
he's that superstar and it's he doesn't
have to help around him and meanwhile
here comes patrick homes here comes
lamar jackson here comes kyler murray
but look the texans believe in him
and he's there and and you know even
with the long-term contract if he ever
does sufficiently sour on the
organization and decides he wants out
kind of hard to keep a franchise
quarterback around who doesn't want to
be there the you have a contract deal
with it attitude doesn't work with the
guy who sets the tone from the locker
room and and here's here's the thing
you've already set the precedent
by what you did with deandre hopkins he
didn't want to be there anymore you
trade him if deshaun watson gets to the
point where he doesn't want to be there
anymore
you trade him
and i don't know that it gets burned
down to that point in houston a lot of
it hinges on the next gm and the next
head coach
but
i think back to the the video
from last hour of the question being
posed to deshaun watson about deandre
hopkins and the yeah well the questions
it's like yeah this this guy's not
comfortable right now and they better do
something to make him comfortable chris
or he's going to want out of there
eventually it may not be next year yeah
may not be the year after but eventually
he's going to want out if they don't
start turning this thing around yeah you
know you know you're right and i don't
think we're there yet i mean it has been
two playoffs appearances the last two
years you know last year they did get a
win finally had that lead in kansas city
but you know to your point
yeah if houston's smart they have a
special guy
a special person with charisma
special person in the community
i those type of guys usually don't want
to leave where they were drafted because
they want to they think hey i'm the man
i'm going to make this team good and
we're going to win super bowls here i
planted my flag here he's i think he's
that type of individual and they just
need to go all in with him and i just
you know offensive genius this year in
the head you know head coaching search
all those things and start framing the
team around him just like mahomes or
kyla murray or even josh allen has or
you know uh in their perspective careers
perspective i talked yesterday about
teams that have turned it around
dramatically the dolphins have done it
we were talking about the 1999
st louis rams yeah has there ever been a
team i mean think about it think about
it
the texans are up 21 nothing in the
first half at kansas city
from the moment bill o'brien twenty two
sides not no i'm saying it was 21-0 and
he freaked himself out and he went for
the field goal when he could have
delivered the dagger and made it 28 but
from the moment it's 21
and he
from that moment where
has there ever been a fall
like this one that fast
where it's all just collapsing and he's
gone after he was made the general
manager following the season he's gone
deandre hopkins is gone
you get the sense jj watt can't wait to
get the hell out of there yeah and just
this vague who knows what's going to
happen next it's just amazing to see how
quickly a team that was in position to
deliver the dagger to the chiefs because
i think if it gets to 28 nothing even
with patrick mahomes if he gets to 28
it's it's a little bit too much to
expect 24 gives you that opening and uh
i just i it's amazing and i feel bad for
desean watson because he's one of our
favorites too we got a lot of favorites
a lot of these young quarterbacks we
love yeah and he's the one that's been
forgotten because he doesn't he you know
we talk about who's got help around them
he's got nothing no got nothing you know
it's um
a wide receiving core that's i overrated
and i think a lot of people did you know
there's no running game and it is a
pitiful defense i mean a pitiful defense
and that's this is again where
you know this is one of those where i'm
glad we're having this conversation
because i think a lot of people will be
able to this is one of those where hey
yeah they're two and seven but it ain't
his fault it ain't the quarterback and
it's more than the quarterback it's not
about one guy all the time and i think
he's the perfect example and oddly
enough i don't think you know most times
when you pick a quarterback who's two
and seven in the top ten you get
pushback from you know people on social
media
i i would imagine most people are gonna
go yeah i can't really push back i know
he's awesome it's just the team is
really that bad
you're getting pushback though from a
couple of omissions let's start with tom
brady fresh prince of rofo i love that
name only one question where is brady
and mitch milani what about the number
of big time throws brady has made this
year look at the turnaround this team
has made with him he's made his
offensive line better and his defense
better by protecting the ball why is
hashtag tommy not in your top ten well
listen
he's he was on the edge okay just for
those that are looking at my top ten
like derek carr
tom brady they were the next names up in
this
now brady's been really good there's no
doubt okay it's an all-star team there
in tampa i mean we talked about weapons
and all those you know with mahomes in
the top five quarterbacks i mean if we
were gonna rank them i think tampa's
gonna end up being number one probably
in the whole league let alone it's a
great defense and all those things so
yes he's making plays i know that but
it's just i'm not going to sit here and
go oh it's plays that
nobody can make i'm sorry but all six
quarterbacks that we've just talked
about would make all those plays that
tom brady did and more and so will the
next guys on my list as we go through
here so that it's not a it's not a thing
against him and then the other thing
that you get into is again yeah they got
three losses all right then i start to
think well how did they lose those three
losses oh well
big part of that was tom brady you know
i mean period you could blame really all
three of them maybe okay i'll run both
saints games and then that chicago game
hey that was a tough night and you
certainly can blame him for the third
and fourth down thing right so he's
right on the edge i'm really love
watching him they're one of my favorite
watches because of their aggressive
passing game and you know just seeing
how they're tinkering with him but no
you know me mike i put a little too much
stock into
when nothing is not when nothing is
there
and you got to make plays and do all of
that what happens and to me that's where
he's you know at this point of his
career just not on the level of some of
these other guys
we've been wrestling with the question
of mvp
ben roethlisberger the steelers if they
would finish the season 16-0 and that's
still an uphill climb even with only
seven games left and a 9-0 record
somebody from that organization has to
be an mvp candidate why not the
quarterback
why isn't ben at least in your top 10
given what the team is doing we saw last
year steelers without ben
struggle and struggle and struggle now
with ben back
same team otherwise they're nine and oh
how is he not in your top ten well you
know again it's it's more than one
player as we always talk about you know
it's still a really good football team
and they were in the playoff
conversation
all year
or at the end of the year with
the worst quarterbacks playing in
football and they were still in the
playoffs i mean the worst quarterback
situation in the league last year was
pittsburgh okay maybe i'm wrong but it's
one of the top two two or three worst
all right it's down there
and they were still
had a fighting chance big ben's been
phenomenal but the way they play
as compared to the other guys on this
list it's not about big ben and
everything
you know big ben has the luxury of hey
they kind of just take it slow on
offense hey we got a great defense i
don't need to push the issue
oh it's ugly for the first two quarters
all right now we've kind of figured it
out i know how you're attacking us now
we'll slowly start to take a few chances
and oh boom boom boom but you know it
has been great he's taking care of the
ball and he's still a great deep ball
thrower but again you know i just go
back to the same thing a lot of these
other guys here you know the the success
of their team is all predicated on them
from the get-go where the game starts
it's about them and they got to make it
happen and that's how their team plays
and big ben at this point of his career
that's not how pittsburgh plays so he's
doing really good he's doing awesome i
mean he still can throw that damn ball
um but they're playing a complete game
where he's managing the game and then
finding his moments to take a shot here
and there and i think there's something
to be said about that as compared to
some of the other guys on here
it really is though easy for steelers
fans and roethlisberger supporters to
argue he's not getting the proper
respect issues i i get it your list just
otherwise generally yeah and and he's
the the big he's the the change factor
no matter how bad those guys were last
year he's the guy that's back and here's
this team at nine
yeah and it's and and i think it looks
this is this is good
because this is one of the things mike
tomlin can use
to keep his guys a little bit upset a
little bit salty the chip on the
shoulder right you don't have the
accolades pouring in the direction of
ben roethlisberger so i i think that it
serves you well as you try to finish the
job of 16-0 nobody's going to get soft
and nobody's going to get big-headed
because no one's praising ben
rothsberger the way they should no no i
i think there is something to that yes
it's truly a team effort and i think
part of the reason he's not getting more
of like you know the headlines and
things like this is because hey think
back about the start of the year i mean
the first five six weeks of the year you
know you were saying i was saying i
don't know about the steelers and their
offense has these moments and they're
not putting teams away and all of that
right you know to where
you know that's again i i'm i'm taking
that into account i know it's been
awesome just as of late but he was
afforded the luxury early on in the year
to go like hey team let me get used to
playing football again and let me get in
a rhythm and everything like that and
again i would argue that you know the
majority of my guys in the top ten it's
not about that the the team and
everything they do is about them
the serials have had two convincing
overpowering wins this year and it just
happened to come in the two games out of
nine where i picked them to lose against
the browns and against the bengals they
blew both teams out otherwise it's been
a fight every week which makes going 9-0
even more impressive
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports